from a young age we are taught that one
of the greatest risks to our integrity
and flourishing is our own selfishness
we must whenever possible learn to think
more about other people keep in mind how
often we fail to see things from their
point of view and be aware of the small
and large ways in which we disadvantage
and ignore collective interests being
good means at its most basic putting
other people more squarely at the center
of our lives but for some of us the
problem isn't so much that we're
heedless to this advice rather that we
take it far too closely and
remorselessly to heart so mindful our we
have the risks of selfishness we run
into an opposite danger an abnegation of
the self a modesty that borders on self
erasure an automatic impulse to give
everything over to competing parties a
shyness about pressing oneself forward
and a mannequin ability to say no or
cause the slightest frustration to
others and so as a result of our talents
at selflessness we fill our diaries with
obligations to people who bore and drain
us we stick at jobs that neglect our
true talents and we stay for far too
long in relationships with people who
deceive us annoy us and subtly and
possibly with a lot of sentimental
sweetness take us for a very long ride
and then one morning we wake up and find
that the bulk of our life is already
behind us that our best years are spent
and that no one is especially grateful
for our sacrifices that there isn't a
reward in heaven for our renunciations
and that we are furious with ourselves
for mistaking meekness and self
surrender for kindness the priority may
then be to rediscover our latent
reserves of selfishness
the very word may be frightening because
we aren't taught to distinguish as we
must between bad and good versions of
this trait between on the one hand the
kind of selfishness that viciously
exploits and reduces others that
operates with no
and in view that disregards people out
of meanness and negligence and on the
other the kind of selfishness that we
require to get anything substantial done
that lends us the courage to prioritize
our own concerns over the flotsam and
jetsam of daily life that lends us the
spirit to be more forthright about our
interests with people who claim to love
us and that at moments leads us to
sidestep nagging demands not in order to
make people suffer but so that we can
husband our resources and in time be
able to serve the world in the best way
we can with a more fruitfully selfish
philosophy in mind we might fight to
have an hour to ourselves each day we
may do something that could get us
labeled as self-indulgent like having
psychotherapy three times a week or
writing a book but that's vital to our
spirit we might go on a trip on our own
because so much has happened that we
need to process in silence we can't be
good to anyone else until we've serviced
some of our own inner callings a lack of
selfishness may be the fastest route to
turning us into ineffective embittered
and ultimately highly disagreeable
people Hindu philosophy can be a useful
guide here because it divides up our
lives into four stages each with its
distinctive roles and responsibilities
the first is that of The Bachelor
student known as Brahma Sharia the
second that of the householder and
parent grihastha tah and the third that
of the grandparent and semi-retired
adviser vanaprastha but it's the fourth
that is the really interesting age in
this context known as sannyasa this is
the time when after years of service to
other people to business family and
society we finally throw off our worldly
obligations and focus instead on the
development of our psychological and
spiritual sides we might sell up our
house go traveling and wander the world
to learn talk to strangers open our eyes
and nourish our minds in the period of
sannyasa we live simply perhaps by a
beach or the side of a mountain we eat
basic food and have few belongings we
cut our tie
with anyone who has nothing spirit
related to Telus anyone who's on the
make and in too much of a hurry anyone
who doesn't spend a substantial amount
of their time reflecting on the meaning
of being alive
what feels insightful about this
division of existence is that it
acknowledged that a sannyasa way of
living can't be right for everyone at
any time yet on the same score that no
good life can be complete without a
version of it there are years when we
simply have to keep our heads down and
study years when we have to bring up
children and accumulate some capital but
there are also just as importantly years
when what we need to do above all is say
enough enough to material and
superficial demands enough to sexual and
romantic entanglements enough to status
and sociability and instead learn to
turn our minds inwards and upwards
without having to Don the orange robe
favored by Hindu sannyasis
with perhaps few visible signs of a
reorientation to speak of it's open to
all of us to make a psychological move
into a more self focused an inner age we
can convey to those around us that we
aren't lazy mad or callous we just need
to avoid doing the expected things for a
while now we need to fulfill our real
promise by casting aside an idea that is
only ever superficially wise that of
always putting other people first
our perspective cards feature tools for
a wiser karma perspective on life they
help to restore calm and clarity even
during difficult times
you